how are you doing now what's going on
right now kurt everything good with you
oh that's good i'm doing well um you
know just got back
uh last week from the filming of my
movie there
filming and so now it heads to the
editing
editing bay and uh they put it together
for hopefully a release
around christmas time depending on covet
and people back to
to normal and get into the theaters so
we'll see how that plays out so
that's pretty exciting and obviously
free agencies getting back to work a
little bit the next couple days
agency and some film sessions with some
uh some of our top players
and baldi um over the next couple days
so
you know getting back to work a little
bit diving into the draft um
you know starting to work on the
quarterbacks there so uh so all good
just
bouncing around doing a lot of stuff and
then uh you know staying
staying involved with the football game
because we know that's 365.
that's right well let's i'll unpack
those one at a time let's start with the
football um the
retirement of drew brees we were all
expecting it um
he and you and he will share a room
forever more when he gets there
which is going to be the first possible
opportunity for him
um so you you know what it's like to
have a hall of fame
career um and wear that patch on the
chest your your two cents
considerable uh on the retirement of
drew brees kurt warner is what
yeah i mean you know first you look at
big picture and
you're just grateful that you got a
chance to witness one of the greatest
careers
especially at the quarterback position
that we've ever seen
and you know me um i love
the nuances of the position i love
people that can play it
mentally first the ability to process
information and see
things and get through progressions and
those sorts of things
and i don't believe anybody did it
better than drew brees when you know
when i would pop on the film every week
after a sunday slate i couldn't wait to
get to drew because
his ability and you know i always use
the term trying to to simplify the game
as quickly as possible so you want to
eliminate as many defenders as you can
as quickly as possible and then get the
ball to the right guy in a timely
fashion and
that is what drew brees did so well you
know we can sit here no he wasn't the
biggest guy
didn't have the the strongest arm and
you could go down the list of
of things that he didn't possess um from
a physical standpoint
but he more than made up for that with
what he did
mentally his anticipation his accuracy
um you know his uh processing as i just
said and those are things that
uh that i appreciated i think maybe more
than most
because that's how i played the game and
it's how i saw the game and so
i'm gonna miss uh turning on the tape
every week
and watching drew put on the clinics
that he puts on
um and you know i've said for years you
know we've got so many talented players
in the league the aaron rodgers and and
russell wilson's and stuff but whenever
i work with a young kid
and i say if you want to watch somebody
on how to play the position
and the technique in the details of
throwing a football
you watch drew brees because he was such
a technician
with everything that he did and so i'm
gonna miss watching him
um i look forward to having him you know
become a teammate in canton and i look
forward to what he's going to do next i
love the fact that we saw the
announcement today he's going to
join nbc sports and i think that's one
of the biggest
and toughest things about the transition
from something you've done your entire
life and
you know playing as many years in the
nfl as he did is okay what's next
and i think a lot of guys kind of wallow
around trying to figure out okay how do
i
how do i step into something else or
where do i go from here i love that drew
has
a plan he's going to jump right into tv
and i think that's something that will
help make the transition
easier for him and i think because of
all the things that i mentioned he'll be
uh he'll be great on tv
well and again um that's another
similarity between
you and him is that you you stepped
right into broadcasting to
to supplement that you know love of
football that
no longer is an itch scratched by
actual gameplay but here's another
aspect kurt
is um reconstructing your career
after the place where you started um
you know broke up with you in a way you
know and
and uh just his just his drafting in
in the second round obviously it's
different in terms of
you and you and he and the fact that you
won a super bowl right from the get-go
and then had another super bowl
appearance in your first spot but
he is synonymous with new orleans
and you went to two different places
including arizona which you took to a
super bowl
and you know won a a walter payton man
of the year award so
you brought your philanthropy to a new
town what is that like what what what do
you think that's like and what he's
thinking about today that he's
retired from the nfl with that on his
resume
i think there's so many cool things
about the way it played out and as you
said when we
hear drew brees name we automatically
think of new orleans and i think a lot
of people kind of forget
about his time with the chargers um
but but i love you know some of those
things we could talk about
you know the six foot plateau and you
know everybody's saying oh he's not
prototypical he can't play the game he
can't play quarterback in the nfl
at that size he opened up a door uh
for so many guys to follow and for so
many teams to look at the quarterback
position
differently because not only did he play
the position but he played the position
inside the pocket showing that you can
be a great passer
and a great pocket passer even at that
size uh the other part
as you mentioned um you know one of the
hardest things to do
is you know when one team basically says
oh
no you're not good enough we're moving
on we're going to draft another
quarterback
so hard uh to be able to change the
perception
of who you are um going somewhere else
and then you know you couple that with
the injury
that he had on top of it and so to be
able to reshape
his career and to reshape it the way
that he did becoming
one of the greatest to ever play the
game after one team said nope you're not
good enough
i think that also is an inspiration to
so many
people out there and you know i can look
at myself
in in the same manner that you know one
team said okay we're moving on we're
going
you know you can't do it anymore and
that challenge of
you know changing people's perception
around the league of what you can be and
what you can do
and he did that as well as anybody and
so i look at those two things and
see how he shapes the minds of people
moving forward whether that be
organizations and how they look at
different guys or young guys you know
coming through things and saying well
everybody's told me i'm too small or
you know this team said i wasn't good
enough um you know
he changes the way that that people kind
of drive and move towards
whatever their goals are because of some
of the things that he accomplished so
uh just a it's going to be a storied
career you know something you know
we can sit back and say i don't know if
we're going to see much like this even
though the numbers are crazy now in the
nfl but
just what he did the consistency by
which he did it
is rare and um you know just so much fun
to watch
him do what he did and um you know as a
fan like i said i was kind of holding
out that maybe we get to see a little
bit more but
excited for him and brittany and the
family they've done so many wonderful
things
and i don't i don't think they're done
yet there's a lot more for him to
accomplish and i look forward to
watching him
in the next chapter kurt warner here on
the rich eisen show um
what is your first blush uh analysis of
the quarterback class coming through in
the draft
that is kind of uh i guess bubbling now
just beneath the surface now that free
agency is about to hit and
teams might uh fill roles uh in that
regard
um through free agency what what is your
uh first plus assessment of the
quarterback class
in 2020 yeah you know i'm interested to
see
how this plays out uh you know i've only
studied a couple of the guys i've really
only studied
trevor lawrence and justin fields so far
um and obviously some some things to
really like about those guys
um you know also some things that i saw
on tape that i thought
i got some things to work on oh they're
in the warnings corner already they're
in the warner's corner already kurt
these kids are
they're not there yet but okay they'll
be there okay they'll be there
um you know so but but you know that's
the case with every young quarterback is
that there's always going to be a lot to
like and then there's going to be some
deficiencies that you sit back and go
okay
this is what they're going to have to be
better at
at the next level if they're going to
become what we think
they can become and that becomes this
process you know you know me i'm not
a huge draft guy or analyst when it
comes to
college to pro because i just there's so
many factors that go into that
that i've seen guys that come out of
college as great players
and they never really progress in the
nfl and they kind of disappear and then
we've seen other guys like the tom
brady's
uh or maybe myself that's right you know
aren't all that
coming out of college but we continue to
progress and grow and get better and get
better and then
you know one day you find yourself
you're kind of at the top of the
mountain and so
it's so hard for me to look at these
guys oh this guy's gonna be great and
this guy i don't know if he's got it
because
you know there's so much that has to
happen and you have to put them
at the speed and the complexity of the
nfl and then really assess them
so you know so much of this is just
speculation
uh but again i i think we've got a class
that that shows a lot of really good
things
and finding themselves in the right
situations
a lot of these guys i think have a
chance to be really good starters
in the nfl but from what i've seen and
as i said i've really only
you know studied two guys in depth yeah
there's also some deficiencies there
and things that i think they're going to
have to get better at
uh to become the upper echelon of of an
nfl quarterback what's trevor lawrence's
deficiencies that you saw
kurt um you know i think there's a
couple things that you know sometimes he
gets away from his technique and when i
say that i mean
um he can get really wide in his his
base and when he tries to put the ball
out there there's times to me that the
ball hangs a little bit
and you know hanging in college is
different than hanging in the pros oh
yes the ball hangs at all on you
gets away from you doesn't get there as
quick as you want it to um
you know that goes the other direction i
think he's a great athlete
but i think he needs to get better at
making athletic throws
and what i mean by that is when your
body's moving in different directions
or the quicker throws where you don't
always get set and you got to bring your
body and you got to be accurate with
some of those things
um you know i think there's there's some
things that he's got to work on there
he's a great athlete though i mean he
can do so many things
uh you know from an athletic standpoint
but there's a
a way to play the position athletically
and i look at a guy like a patrick
mahomes or an aaron rodgers
in all the ways that they're able to
throw the football and use their body
and be accurate
um you know when they're falling away
from pressure and they're
they're moving out of the pocket and um
you know so some of those things that i
think
he's going to have to get better at
because you don't always get to set up
in the nfl right it doesn't always get
to be picture perfect
uh you got to make sure that you're
ready for some of those things and be
more fluid
with some of those things which is
something that uh that i think he'll
have to get better at
sorry in the nfl okay that's your dog
again is that you do you
we're going live well i got to tell you
kurt you're i think you're a lone wolf
in criticizing trevor lawrence
i think that's what that i think that's
what stella's saying you're alone
william
that is probably true i can't criticize
him you're not
chris and i know you're positive just
analyzing
the big picture uh kurt warner a couple
minutes left uh with curt right now what
is alex smith thinking right now
do you think cause so many people are
like you know what urban was his college
coach
trevor needs to be coached by a
professional what it's like to be a
professional
that's what alex smith is gonna do and
i'm sitting here thinking i don't know
if that's what alex smith is
thinking you know he might come around
to that i mean that might be what winds
up happening but
what do you think's going through this
veteran's head right now
kurt i just think what goes through alex
smith had is
come on people i mean at some point
give me credit for being a good starter
a winning quarterback in the national
football league
it just seems like everywhere he goes
it's always like well
you know we're going to find someone
better we're going to find someone
better
i mean it happened in san fran then it
happened in kansas city and now it
happens in one i mean
here's a guy that comes in after
everything he's been through and leads
them to the playoffs
and now it's like uh we're gonna move on
he's not he's not good enough
you know it's just like give me a little
bit of respect on my name has
got to be what alex smith is thinking
because he is so good in so many facets
and he would make any team better um
then i'm sure he's just kind of going
why i mean how many times do i have to
do this before i can
find a home where somebody you know will
entrust
um you know the situation to me and not
have to you know always look over
my shoulder so i think that's the first
thing that he's thinking
but the second thing is you know for any
free agent quarterback
right now there's just not a lot of
spots out there
you know there's not a lot of situations
where you can go and
and be you know the bona fide starter
and people are going to you know pay you
as a starter and turn the keys over to
you with
a lot of young guys in the league and
possible movement
um you know with the guys that are
coming in the draft that you know we've
got a good crop of quarterbacks in the
draft that teams could decide to
you know like your team at the jets
right could easily decide hey we're
going to go
wilson or someone at number two and now
sam darnold becomes free
and so then you have alex smith or sam
darnold and
most people are gonna go well let me
take my chance with a sam darnold
because we could get the guy
um to be the franchise guy for for the
long term and so
i i think it's going to be interesting
with um you know guys like alex smith
and you know which of these you know uh
which of these things kind of fall with
these different organizations that
decide to go
you know in the draft and then they have
a guy that becomes free
and then of course if you know if one of
these big dominos falls with
watson or wilson which i don't think in
my opinion is going to happen but if one
of those things happened
that could shake everything up a little
bit more so
alex smith may end up finding himself in
a situation
like that which i don't think is ideal
because i know he wants to be a starter
and you don't want to just
you know keep the seat warm until the
next guy's ready that's never where you
want to go especially
later in your career but i think it may
play out that way for alex unfortunately
just because there's not a lot of spots
out there
all right kurt uh before i let you go
you and i are going to talk on nfl
network in about half an hour actually
so
for the free agency frenzy uh before i
let you go
um your movie that i've been hearing
about for so long that everybody thinks
you know should have been made the
minute that you won your championship
back in 1999 uh i've known you
uh as a as a colleague at nfl network
for a decade plus now
this this movie's shot it's in the can
as they say
it it is in the can you know with all
the challenges of covid and all the
protocols
um you know everybody through lions um
did an unbelievable job of of pushing
through and getting through this and
filming it and so
yeah it's happening uh you know it has
been a long time coming and a process to
get
the story right and the essence right
and i think we're there
um you know at least with the shooting
in the script and everything up to that
point and
um now it's how they piece it together
so we're extremely
excited about where it's at the people
that are involved
um the way that it's been you know
worked together
um and then we're excited to see you
know when it all comes to the big screen
okay you know how that plays out it's uh
but yes
it's in the can it is definitely
happening it uh
it really just comes down to a matter of
win right now okay so a few questions on
this
uh the the working title or it's a title
is that
is the working title or where you got a
title right now uh for the film the
title is american underdog
american underdog and i know you're
played by the actor zachary levi who's
known
best for being chuck and shazam for the
yeah for
tv and film um and then there's some
other important roles that i'm concerned
about
um first of all brenda warner played by
who who's brendan
anna paquin is a big-time celebrity and
actress
okay okay dick vermeel is played by
um why am i drawing a blank right now oh
no
oh it's okay yeah that is
is marshall falk portrayed in this film
as well is too right on this one
not not a big role more of a football
role so nobody um
you know nobody specific playing
marshall spot okay
um and i just wanted to thank you in
advance of getting uh brad pitt to play
me
in your broadcasting part of the film so
thank you for that how did you look
uh um he looked good that that scene got
cut
but he looked really good in the scene
really who's going to tell brad that
who's going
i don't know well actually actually you
know i shouldn't say that so i think
they had a scene of you talking about
how the rams are going to suck
warner taking over for trent green
that that scene that scene may make the
movie
we'll have to see i never said that on
sportscenter i never
said that the thing is is brad pitt
doesn't have to play you for that that
that's legit we can just
we can just go back in the archives and
find that one so i'm assuming since i
never got a call
there is no nfl network in in american
underdog it's just about your playing
it's it it's just about that one year
there is there is not uh no so he
doesn't doesn't go beyond the playing
career no
okay in the credits there's a guy named
man in chicken suit
are you serious yeah have you already
looked this up yeah it's not looking
up right now who's the chick who's man
in chicken soup that was me
yeah i don't know who played that role
but what's the point there's no doubt
that it went back to arena football when
we played in a place called the barn so
it had to be a part of the barn i'm
assuming
[Laughter]
all right kurt these are many questions
i have
uh for for uh now that you're outside of
principle shooting uh we'll we'll handle
it moving forward
congrats on that i'm very happy for you
and the fam
thank you thank god we are excited all
right kurt very good i'll be invited to
the uh oscar party i hope one day
um well yeah i don't know let's not go
that far you can come to the premiere
we'll
you can go on another magic carpet ride
it's you kurt let's focus on
all the possibilities okay well we'll
cross that bridge but i look forward to
talking to you
more about it uh as we move forward for
sure all right kurt i'll chat with you
on nfl network in literally about a half
an hour we'll check
all right sounds good guys thank you
yeah that's kurt warner everybody hey
you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here